معنا من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح
وسط قطاع غزه مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط
هشام اين تركز القصف الاسرائيلي صباح هذا
اليوم وما الذي اسفر عنه حتى
الان القصف يتركز على المنطقه الوسطى
وربما الان بعض على ما يبدو الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه تطلق قذائف دخانيه
على منطقه قريبه هنا من محيط مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى منذ صباح هذا اليوم القصف المدفعي
لم يتوقف قص من الطائرات الحربيه ايضا
استمر وتواصل على مناطق عده في وسط القطاع
واستهدف في جله منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه لكن
الدبابات الاسرائيليه تكثف من قصفها لهذه
المناطق منذ عده ساعات والقصف مستمر
متواصل عمليات اطلاق النار ايضا على شارع
صلاح الدين مستمره ومتواصله وكما نرى هذه
بقايا على ما يبدو قنابل دخانيه اطلقتها
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه والاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه على هذه المناطق في محيط
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى ربما مخيمات المغازي
والبريج والنصيرات تتعرض في كل لحظه وفي
كل حين الى قصف مدفعي عنيف يسمع ايضا
اصوات اشتباكات ما بين الفينه والاخرى على
ما يبدو انها ناجمه عن اشتباكات ما بين
عناصر المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي على ما يبدو تحاول التقدم
والتوغل ب لمدا ايات اعلى في وسط قطاع غزه
لا سما في مخيم النصيرات مخيم البريج
وايضا مخيم المغازي كل هذه المخيمات باتت
الدبابات الاسرائيليه على اطرافها وتحاول
على ما يبدو من خلال القصف الاسرائيلي
تمهيد الطريق للدخول من جديد والى قلب هذه
المناطق حتى الان الدبابات الاسرائيليه
متواجده في على اطراف مخيم البريج ايضا
متواجده في على اطراف مخيم المغازي تطلق
النار في مخيم المغازي ربما له خصوصيه لا
سما وان القصف الاسرائيلي بات مكثفا على
مخيم المغازي هناك قناصه يعتلون بعض
العمارات المرتفعه في مخيم المغازي
ويطلقون النار على المواطنين الذين
يحاولون الخروج او النزوح حتى من هذا
المخيم لكن يطلقون النار عليهم هناك عماره
على مدخل مخيم المغازي على شارع صلاح
الدين يتواجد بعض القناصه عليها ويطلقون
النار على كل من يحاول التحرك او حتى قطع
الطريق من الجهه الغربيه الى الجهه
الشماليه كما نستمع الان الى اصوات هذه
الانفجارات هي مزيد من القناب الدخانيه
وهذه القنابل الدخانيه على مدار الايام
الماضيه هي وقنابل فسفوريه كانت تطلق على
هذه المناطق منطقه الزوايده ومنطقه مخيم
المغازي وهذه ربما تطلق على اطراف مخيم
المغازي او ما بين المنطقه ما بين مخيم
المغازي وبلده الزوايده وهذه المناطق
تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه وهذه القنابل الدخانيه تشير
ربما الى محاوله الدبابات الاسرائيليه
المتواجده التي باتت متواجده ما بين دير
البلح ومخيم المغازي تحاول على ما يبدو
التقدم من جديد والتمركز والتموضع في
مناطق مختلفه عن تلك التي كانت متواجده
فيها على مدار اليومين الماضيين على الاقل
لا سما وان الجيش الاسرائيلي والدبابات
الاسرائيليه توغلت من محور مخيم المغازي
بالاضافه الى استمرار توغلها من مخيم من
الاطراف الشرقيه لمخيم البريج وبالتالي
بات المخيم مخيم المغازي يتعرض الى قصف
عنيف من الطائرات من المت عيه حتى ان
سيارات الاسعاف ممنوعه من الدخول الى هذا
المخيم وبالتالي هناك اعداد من الاصابات
واعداد من الشهداء مازالت متواجده على
الارض لم تستطع الطواقم اجلاء او انتشال
الجثامين من تلك المناطق الناس تحاول
الدخول من بعض الطرق الفافيه من اجل
الخروج من مخيم المغازي الذي يقع على شرق
شارع صلاح الدين وا الذهاب الى دير البلح
لكن حتى هذا هذه الطرق بات اطلاق النار
عليها مكثفا القصف المدفعي مستمر ومتواصل
وايضا القصف يستهدف منازل يتواجد فيها
السكان وبالتالي هناك اعداد من الاصابات
وحتى منذ ايام نستمع الى مناشدات من قبل
المواطنين يطالبون المؤسسات الدوليه
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر وطواقم
الاسعاف بالتوجه الى مخيم المغازي من اجل
انتشال واجلاء المصابين لكن حتى الان لم
تتمكن هذه الطواقم من التوجه الى تلك
المناطق بسبب القصف الكثيف والاخطر من كل
ذلك ان هناك مسيرات اطلقتها اطلقها جنود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كواد كابتر تطلق
النار على كل من يحاول الدخول الى هذه
المخيمات هذه المسيرات خلال ساعات الليل
وساعات الفجر الاولى كانت منتشره بشكل
كثيف في سماء اغلب المحافظه الوسطى في
منطقه الزوايده وفي منطقه مخيم النصيرات
وفي مخيم المغازي وفي مخيم البريج وكانت
تطلق النار على المواطنين الذين كانوا
يحاولون مع ساعات الفجر الاولى الدخول
والخروج من من هذا المخيم الان مزيد من
هذه القذائف الدخانيه و على ذات المنطقه
التي تستهدفها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وهي على ما يبدو قريبه جدا من مدخل بلده
الزوايده وشارع صلاح الدين من المعروف انه
بات مغلقا بشكل كامل بعدما تقدمت الدبابات
الاسرائيليه من مخيم المغازي على هذا
الشارع وايضا كانت توغلت وقطعت الطريق من
مدينه غزه وبالتالي بات هذا الشارع ايضا
من جهه دير البلح مغلق بشكل كامل بسبب
التواجد للاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
وبالتالي بات من الخطير حتى لسيارات
الاسعاف التوجه من الغرب اي المكان الذي
نتواجد فيه في مستشفى شهداء الاقصى الى
المناطق الشرقيه ك قريه المصدر وايضا مخيم
المغازي وايضا مخيم البريج وبالتالي بات
من الصعب الوصول الى هذه الاصابات وايضا
انتشال الجثامين من تلك المناطق التي
تتعرض الى الاستهداف بشكل مباشر وعلى مدار
الساعه شكرا لك هشام زقوت مراسل الجزيره
كنت معنا من دير البلح